this is what some people call a ghost
gun
it's an ar-15 semiautomatic rifle that
has no serial number it's untraceable I
didn't have to go through a background
check or any sort of waiting period to
get it the government has no knowledge
of its existence in fact and that's
because legally speaking I didn't buy
this gun I made it
anyone can buy every part of an ar-15 on
the Internet there's one part though
that you can't buy without a background
check and that is a functioning lower
receiver the body of the gun what you
can buy is this this is not a lower
receiver although it looks a lot like
one to the governments this is legally
just a chunk of aluminum but to any
gunsmith it's an 80 percent lower that's
a lower receiver that's basically 80%
finished all you have to do is remove a
few cavities of aluminum from this and
you're left with a true functioning gun
for years
DIY gun makers have been legally
creating their own lower receivers to
skirt gun control laws and build
untraceable weapons I wanted to see if
new digital tools could make building
one of these ghost guns easier for
someone like me with little firearms or
power tools experience if I can legally
make a semi-automatic rifle and
circumvent all gun control anyone can so
I tried making my air 15 lower receiver
three different ways with a traditional
drill press with a 3d printer and with a
new computer-controlled milling machine
called the ghost gunner the first I'm
gonna try to do this the old-fashioned
manual way well that was really not good
supposed to be a hole there this is now
detached from this and I mean though
that wasn't supposed to happen
I've just made like a total mess of the
inside of this thing I don't think that
this is a working firearm component by
any means so next I used a MakerBot
replicator and free plans I downloaded
from the web to 3d prints a plastic
ar-15 lower receiver from scratch
process was incredibly easy but the
results were somewhat flawed I cut a
finger trying to remove excess plastic
finally I tried what could be the future
of homemade gunsmithing the $1500 ghost
gunner is a computer-controlled milling
machine the latest invention of Defence
distributed a controversial group known
for releasing 3d printable blueprints
for gun parts including a fully 3d
printable pistol the ghost gunner
doesn't print parts in plastic though it
machines them out of aluminum and it
works on the same 80% lower as I tried
with the drill press method but requires
far less equipment and skill as I
watched the ghost gunner precisely carve
away aluminum it became clear that the
barrier to legally obtaining a fully
metal untraceable semi-automatic rifle
is lower than ever before this is the
beautifully milled aluminum lower
receiver for an air 15 that we built
today before I put actual explosive
rounds through anything I'd made I
thought I should check my work with a
professional so I took my box of gun
parts the Nathan rinder at Bay Area
gunsmithing please don't laugh this is
the lower that I tried to make what the
drill was a drill oh I've seen worse
than this
Nathan argue that only the lower
receiver I'd made with the ghost gunner
was functional and safe we could totally
assemble this he was nice enough to let
me muddle through the final assembly of
the ar-15 at his shop i test-fired my
homemade ar-15 for the first time at a
nearby firing range I can't take this
boom with me on a flight back to New
York and I can't sell it to anyone here
in San Francisco or even give it to
someone else
at Wired legally so instead I have to
take it apart and either destroy or turn
over to the police the lower receiver
that was the end of my ghost gun but
it's just the beginning for a defense
distributed ghost gunner the group has
already sold more than a thousand of its
milling machines everyone is a tiny
anarchic rifle Factory and if they work
as well as the one I tested there will
be many more ghost guns to come